[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce lundi 19 novembre
la mobilisation des gilet jaune a pris
également dans les yvelines samedi des
points de blocage en portant sur la
nationale 12 et l'a13 qui ont convergé
au niveau du triangle de rocquencourt
retour sur la journée et bilan en
plateau avec alain allongé rynnas qui a
participé à la manifestation
il est le secrétaire départemental de
deux bouts la france à l'occasion de la
journée mondiale de l'enfance trappe
organise sa semaine de l'éducation elle
est dédiée aux enfants aux parents et à
la communauté éducative de nombreuses
animations vont rythmer ce rendez vous
point d'orgue avec les de l'événement
samedi nous en parlons avec jeanine
marie maire-adjointe de trappes et puis
la chronique sports du lundi avec du
football versailles dernier représentant
des yvelines en coupe de france le club
s'est qualifié hier pour le 8e tour de
la compétition
cette information pour débuter
aujourd'hui carlos ghosn a été arrêté à
tokyo le pdg de l'alliance renault
nissan mitsubishi a été entendue par les
autorités locales pour malversation
selon nissan il aurait pendant des
années déclaré et des revenus inférieurs
au montant réel au fisc japonais
préjudice estimé à plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros
le constructeur asiatique va proposer au
conseil d'administration de démettre
carlos ghosn de son poste
conséquence à la bourse de paris le
titre du groupe renault implantée
notamment dans les yvelines à guyancourt
et flins a chuté de plus de 12% et dans
un communiqué le syndicat sud renault du
technocentre critique
l'exemplarité du pdg qui a la charge de
470 mille salariés la date du 17
novembre a marqué décidément les esprits
les français opposés à la hausse des
taxes sur le carburant appelait à
bloquer le pays
le mouvement d'idées gilet jaune a été
marquée par plusieurs opérations
notamment dans les yvelines de nombreux
axes ont été bloqués par les
manifestants
reportage sur place de manon varaldo et
de nicolas landry
[Musique]
les gilet jaune signe de ralliement des
français mécontents du prix des
carburants ont manifesté dans les
yvelines
la mobilisation a commencé samedi 17
novembre au matin avec l'opération
escargot de saint nom la bretèche qui a
été rejoint par les manifestants venus
de rambouillet rassemblement également
sur le secteur de ville propre plaisir
les motards ont ouvert le convoi ya un
an de ça se faisait mon plein de sens
tant pis pour 45 euros
maintenant on est sûr on est serein 45
quand je paye 60 euros donc quand même
une petite évolution la zone commerciale
des clayes-sous-bois était bloqué par
petits groupes les manifestants traverse
les passages piétons pour bloquer les
conducteurs derrière ce mouvement d
gilet jaune se cache diverses
revendications d'abord celle des
automobilistes
exaspérés par la hausse des taxes sur le
carburant mais aussi celle des salariés
qui voient les coûts de la vie augmenter
depuis des années des années les
salaires ils sont bloqués ils sont
jeunes et mêmes ils diminuent alors
aujourd'hui bas on travaille on
travaille toujours plus mais c'est pour
gagner moi alors là du coup il y en a
ras-le-bol
parmi les gilet jaune le site des futurs
retraités dont le pouvoir d'achat est
impacté par la hausse de la csg
ça fait mois des années je travaille je
vais arriver à la retraite j'ai 1500
euros de salaire donc je vais me
retrouver avec une retraite de 1200
euros
eh bien avec ça on vit pas et quand ils
nous il faut qu'ils viennent nous
expliquer ce qu'ils décident de
continuer à me faire les poches
comment vit avec sa suite aux
mobilisations la gendarmerie a décidé de
fermer l'a13 au niveau du triangle de
rocquencourt
les manifestants se sont ensuite tous
donné rendez vous sur le parking d'une
discothèque à louveciennes il faut se
faire comprendre
à partir du moment où on fait que
d'augmenter les prix nous on en a
ras-le-bol eux c'est bien
il encaisse il inquiète six enquêtes
mais nous on est déjà dans la merde à
partir du moment où on est déjà dans la
merde ils peuvent pas nous foute six
pieds sous terre
les gilet jaune mécontents des annonces
du gouvernement espère que ce mouvement
sera prolongée et lance un nouvel appel
à bloquer paris samedi 24 novembre et
pas de chiffres à vous donner
précisément sur les i mean la préfecture
n'a pour le moment pas communiqué sur
cette journée pour en parler en tout cas
avec mon plateau à alain longet renass
bonsoir en soin d'aller vous êtes le
secrétaire départemental de debout la
france dans les yvelines alors vous
étiez vous dans le blocage sur la
nationale 12 samedi
ça s'est déroulée cette journée tombe
alors en ce qui concerne notre blocage
s'est très bien déroulé l'organisateur
avait bien fait les choses il s'était
rapproché des autorités la manifestation
avait été déclarée en préfecture ce qui
fait qu'on a eu une coopération très
intelligente avec la gendarmerie qui a
été présente durant toute la journée et
il n'y a pas eu le moindre le moindre
débordement c'était une ambiance très
bon enfant
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'on
est on était aux environs de 200 à 300
dans le dans le blocage que il y avait
une population très très diverses
il y avait des retraités y avait
beaucoup de jeunes et ça ça m'a ça m'a
frappée parce qu'on a on constate qu'il
ya une prise de conscience auprès des
jeunes que bâle à agir à la politique
c'est important qu'on l'avait beaucoup
de sujets aussi pas que sur la hausse
des carburants il ya une grogne
on va dire plus globale sur la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat aussi c'est ce qu'on a
pu observer c'est clair je crois que
l'essence fin le prix du gasoil et de
l'essence c'est un catalyseur qui fait
que les gens aujourd'hui se retrouvent
massivement dans la rue il entre 500
mille et un million de participants au
niveau national et pourquoi y réagissent
à ce niveau là c'est parce que avant ça
il ya eu toute une cascade de taxes qui
ont augmenté sur l'électricité sur le
gaz on nous avait annoncé une baisse de
la taxe d'habitation c'est absolument
pas le cas moi à titre personnel voilà
bien je peux vous le dire elle a
augmenté de plus de 10%
donc on s'aperçoit que le gouvernement
gérait pas jusqu'à dire qu'ils mentent
mais en tout cas il essaie de masquer
les choses de minimiser les choses mais
là aujourd'hui ça se voit sérieusement
et c'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
citoyens parce que c'est avant tout une
opération citoyenne se sont mobilisés et
ça risque à mon avis de recommencer et
compte tenu la réponse l'appel qui a été
lancé pour pour bloquer paris notamment
des appels aussi dans toute la france
vous dirais que ça a été efficace quand
même cette journée de mobilisation
moi je dirais que oui parce que on a vu
que massivement les gens participer on a
vu aussi que massivement les gens' les
gens se sont comportés calmement
l'objectif n'était pas net à certains
endroits c'était de réaliser des
blocages mais pas nécessairement
uniquement de bloquer s'était déjà des
débuts de voir qu'il ya un
mécontentement et à partir de là je
pense que l'objectif a été plus que
largement atteint et la réponse à mon
avis du gouvernement n'est absolument
pas à la hauteur des attentes à
l'occasion d'en parler en fin
d'entretien leur la base vous l'avez dit
c'est un mouvement citoyen les
manifestants ont voulu absolument se
détacher de tout mouvement politique
force est de constater que ça n'a pas
forcément été le cas partout
nos journalistes ont pu voir sur le
terrain des logos politique le président
de debout la france nicolas dupont
aignan avait d'ailleurs appelé à se
mobiliser samedi comme d'autres
représentant les partis d'opposition
n'ont t'ils pas cherché à récupérer
cette masse cette manifestation alors je
dirais qu'ils sont dans le rôle je vois
pas les limites le problème de se lancer
dans une opération de récupération et je
crois que si un parti qui est fondé à
tenter de tout cas de marquer son
soutien
à cette opération s'est bien debout la
france parce qu'il s'agit d' avant tout
d'une colère initiée par les
automobilistes
et ça fait dix ans que debout la france
a initié tout un ensemble d'opérations
et notamment on pense à l'opération au
péage ou nicolas dupont aignan a déjà
été pris en photo vue avec déjà à
l'époque il ya dix ans un gilet jaune
sur lui pour dénoncer le racket qui
s'est opéré sur les automobilistes après
lait les prix visite privatisation des
autoroutes et on l'a encore fait nous
debout la france fédération des yvelines
au mois de juillet à saint-arnoult pour
dénoncer au moment du départ en vacances
cette ce racket qui est opérée d'une
mère général sur les automobilistes a eu
des mots forts du gouvernement notamment
du ministre sébastien lecornu qui
accusent les partis d'opposition j'ai
aussi de faire du recel de la colère des
français
ça vous inspire quoi ça m'inspire qu'il
ya une volonté de la part du
gouvernement de d'abaisser l'impact de
ce mouvement de masquer l'ampleur
l'ampleur de la colère et
à un moment donné de toute façon ces
opérations ont probablement besoin d'un
relais et je pense que c'est à partir de
là que les partis politiques trouvent
toute la noblesse de deux de leurs
actions il ya une personne morte en
savoie à 400 blessés en france plus de
400 blessés ça entache pas de la
mobilisation c'est la décrédibilise pas
selon vous absolument pas parce qu'on
s'aperçoit alors premièrement on
s'aperçoit que souvent les blessés et
les la personne qui malheureusement est
décédé et ça c'est vraiment absolument
dramatique c'est le résultat en fait de
gens qui s'énervent alors que les
blocages était annoncé depuis longtemps
qui perdent leur sang froid et qui font
véritablement n'importe quoi et puis on
constate aussi que les forces de l'ordre
à certains endroits et c'est ce qui
s'est produit à versailles près de la
lanterne ont provoqué les incidents face
à des manifestants qui étaient on ne
peut plus calme et qui manifestaient
leur mécontentement de façon tout à fait
pacifique un moment donné on a bien vu
que les ordres sont tombés et qu on a
demandé aux policiers d'intervenir et de
faire évacuer la zone nous resterons de
secondes edouard philippe sur france 2 a
dit samedi comprendre la colère des
français mais pour autant il ne reculera
pas le gouvernement ne changera pas de
cap
vous êtes con clairement un satisfait de
cette réponse absolument le gouvernement
d'une manière générale se comportent
comme eux et c'est le cas d' emmanuel
macron il se comporte en tant que
président de la république comme un
président de filiale d'une grande
entreprise qui confronté à un mouvement
social décide de faire la sourde oreille
d'ignorer et de dénigrer les
alors que là il s'agit de france et de
citoyens français qui manifestent un
légitime mécontentement et la réponse du
gouvernement est absolument pas à la
hauteur et ça risque d'avoir des
conséquences sur les prochaines
opérations qui risquent d'être à mon
avis encore plus violente parce que les
jambes sont frustrés de cet autisme
qu'on constate de la part du
gouvernement notamment un nouvel appel à
se mobiliser dès samedi prochain à paris
pour des blocages merci alain l'algérie
n'a fait d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le marché hier
grégory finales départementales de
debout la france dans les yvelines
en bref une troisième personne mise en
examen pour homicide volontaire dans la
sphère du meurtre de rachid ce père de
famille mort le 7 novembre après avoir
été rouée de coups devant le lycée à 17
mar à maurepas
le suspect âgé de 16 ans est interpellé
vendredi
il affirme sa présence lors du passage à
tabac mais soutient qu'il n'a pas porté
la main sur la victime deux autres
individus ont déjà été mises en examen
la semaine dernière aux clayes-sous-bois
ont continué de célébrer le centenaire
de la grande guerre ce week-end mais à à
l'accent américain la ville accueillait
un camp militaire de 1917 reconstitué au
parc de diane tenues et outils d'époque
exigé mélanie poker
[Musique]
quelque part en france en 1917 la dix
septième division d'infanterie
américaine s'est installée k1 ce
passionné on reconstruit un campement
type ou presque s'est inscrit dans le
devoir de mémoire et c'est quelque chose
auquel on tient absolument c'est à dire
que pour nous il n'ya pas mieux que
l'histoire vivante pour montrer aux gens
ce qui était la réalité du terrain
si les costumes et certaines temps ne
sont pas d'époque elle les outils week
comme certaines armes ou ces fioles
médical comme celle ci par exemple qui
m'a toujours un petit peu impressionnés
puisque le premier terme que l'on voit
en rouge ces poisons et en fait on est
bien sûr un avril 1916 où 18 je ne sais
plus et le terme de poison sur celle ci
elle est simplement marquer parce que
c'est à base de mercure est des témoins
du passé pour mieux comprendre le
conflit et certaines avancées notamment
médicale et ce n'est qu'à partir du
moment où
les chercheurs les médecins sur site et
tout le corps médical s'est rendu compte
que l'hygiène était primordial qu'on a
commencé à stériliser les outils qu'on a
purifié l'eau qu'on va laver le linge
une plongée dans l'histoire partagée
avec le public qui a bravé le froid et
je trouve que c'est agréable
ne serait ce que pour les enfants leur
montrer un petit peu une idée de ce que
c'était à cette époque là je trouve que
c'est excellent pour la mémoire cela
fait et puis un témoignage un témoignage
autant pour les jeunes que pour nous est
la dix septième compagnie a perdu près
de 7000 hommes en lorraine lors de la
première guerre mondiale
ces soldats là sont rentrés chez eux à
la fin du week-end revenu en 2018
l histoire de la grande guerre
décidément à l'honneur ce week-end dans
ses récents temps de commémoration les
archives départementales des yvelines
organisé samedi une journée autour de 14
18 avec animation et remise de prix le
récit de mélanie poker les images de
nicolas landry plusieurs années de
travail collaboratif mais aussi
plusieurs années d'émotion c'est une
sorte de clap de fin
avec la fin du centenaire de la grande
guerre les archives départementales ans
célébrés nouvelle fois l'histoire à
travers leurs projets collaboratifs
débuter en 2013
une édition qui clôt un peu ce cycle de
commémoration une édition dans la
programmation a été menée conjointement
avec l'ensemble des bénévoles une
édition que l'on voulait avant tout
festive et qui soit une sorte d'hommage
aux contributeurs notamment au travers
de cette exposition photos de portraits
ils sont très actives dans l'ensemble
des projets que l'on mène et sans eux on
pourrait pas arriver à ces résultats les
bénévoles et le public ont voyagé
jusqu'en 1914 en se glissant dans la
peau de poilus du recrutement à l'envoi
de courriers sur le front il y avait une
grosse responsabilité parce que ces
cartes représenté à faire de cette
correspondance représente évidemment
beaucoup et puis
il fallait aussi bien entendu dans
l'autre sens que les la correspondance
écrite par les familles puissent
parvenir
jusqu'au premier lui une journée aussi
marquée par des remises de prix
les passionnés pouvait partir en équipe
à la recherche de gueule d'ange dans un
serious game ya lui huit étapes pour
pouvoir trouver finalement qui est
gueule d'ange on est à la recherche d'un
d'un personnage qui a fait des croquis
et donc on essaie de retrouver le nom de
ce gueule d'ange
je suis une adepte des archives
départementales vont déjà moi je les
connais déjà depuis très longtemps donc
c'était une évidence de fer en fait ce
jeu depuis 2013 plus de 7000 personnes
ont été touchées par l'ensemble des
projets menés par les archives
départementales
ce mardi c'est la journée internationale
des droits de l'enfant à cette occasion
la ville de trappes propose elle une
semaine de l'éducation une des multiples
animations à destination des enfants
bien sûr mais aussi à des parents et de
la communauté éducative point d'orgue
samedi avec la signature du projet
éducatif de territoire bonsoir génie de
marie lancement vous êtes première maire
adjointe de trappes en charge notamment
de l'éducation alors la ville le dit
dans son communiqué de presse annonçant
l'événement
l'éducation c'est la meilleure arme dans
la lutte contre les inégalités
économiques et sociales
pourquoi tout à fait tout à fait c'est
le moment qui se prolonge puisque ça
commence de la crèche jusqu'au au lycée
et quelquefois au delà c'est le moment
de mettre chacun face à ce qu'il peut
donner de lui même pour la société
encore faut-il lui donner les clés on a
une société aujourd'hui qui est pressé
toujours pressé des enfants qui sont
souvent seuls à la maison des enfants
que des parents qui n'ont pas le temps
et puis un déficit de 30 ans
de société qui fait qu'on n'a pas pris
le mal à bras le corps aujourd'hui il
semblerait que 11 ans de dispositions à
l'égard de l'éducation nationale où dès
que le pdt le projet éducatif de
territoire est sorti par monsieur
peillon moi j'ai sauté sur l'occasion
parce que j'ai vu les leviers que cela
permettait pour les enfants de trappes
et il faut bien reconnaître que
maintenant ça va faire bientôt 12 ans
que j'ai cette délégation afin d'agir
auprès des enfants et surtout les
parents parce que sans le parent on peut
rien faire les résultats scolaires
s'améliore et du coup pourquoi créer
l'événement avec cette semaine de
l'éditeur pourquoi se crée l'événement
parce que c'est notre deuxième que d'été
que le se perdent et et s'est enrichi de
l'expérience du premier que nous avions
fait il a été co construit coécrit avec
les partenaires dans toute leur ensemble
y compris les enfants et à partir de là
il est devenu très riche et nous avons
une attractivité qui fait que je pense
que ce deuxième période était va être
bien meilleur que le premier parce que
nous avons initié nous mettons à
disposition de l'éducation nationale sur
le temps scolaire pour que tous les
enfants en bénéficient
les atelier à visée philosophique qui
sont absolument magique
et puis des ateliers théâtre et nous
avons depuis deux ans l'association
enquête qui intervient sur les faits
religieux pour vous simplifier un petit
peu la chose ces deux colonnes la
croyance et la connaissance d'accord et
parfaire a pris à temps car attention
peu l'une chez l'autre et c'est très
efficace et très important d'associer
tout le monde c'est une semaine qui
s'adresse aux enfants voulaient dit
l'importance des parents aussi la
communauté éducative
oui oui on avait le coup de pouce je
prends que c'était jeudi dernier toutes
les écoles étaient représentées ya une
école où il ya des difficultés
particulières c'est pour ça que les
ateliers philosophiques démarre dès la
maternelle jusqu'au cm2 1 maternelle
c'est le réseau rased qui fait la
philosophie et en élémentaire c'est une
association l'association sève
savoir être et vivent ensemble et c'est
tous les niveaux de l'élémentaire qui
ont il ya les parents les enfants
n'étaient pas là et des ateliers aussi
savoir être qu'on a peut être vu à
l'image ou qu'on verra au cours de cet
entretien lors le temps fort de cette
semaine c'est samedi avec la signature
dans l'après midi de ce projet éducatif
de territoire c'est un projet éducatif
qui a été mis en place il ya quatre ans
pour la première fois c'est ça dans la
première fois il est valable trois ans
donc là il démarre en 2018 jusqu'à
l'année scolaire le 1021 je voudrais
devenir de ce nouveau projet éducatif
qui va être signé samedi
et bien c'est toutes les nouveautés qui
a deux à l'intérieur donc les ateliers
que je viens de vous dire l'atelier
théâtre c'est aussi important pour le
bien-être de l'enfant on travaille
énormément sur le bien-être
parce que si on n'est pas bien dans sa
peau je dis toujours en france on a la
tradition du du transmis du savoir et du
savoir faire on n'a pas la transmission
du savoir être or si on n'a pas ce
dernier les deux premiers sont un peu en
déséquilibre et c'est là dessus qu'on
intervient auprès des enfants et met l
estime de soi le plus tôt possible les
signatures qui sera notamment en
présence du préfet des yvelines et du
directeur académique des yvelines alors
sur le programme d'ici samedi un
programme aussi varié attrape notamment
les structures qui sont associés le
grenier à sel l'école de musique et de
danse la librairie mille feuilles pour
ne citer qu'elles mais voilà il y en a
bien d'autres
faut retenir que c'est un programme
varié ya de l'exposition il ya des
ateliers il ya plusieurs choses
proposées tout bien de tous rien du tout
il ya tout ce qui se passe tout au long
de l'année et de ces trois années à
venir qui intervient autour de l'enfant
de façon directe ou indirecte et chacun
peut aller le temps de cette semaine
vérifier comment se passe l'intervention
auprès des enfants comment ils
travaillent ensemble et la journée de
samedi on l'a dit cette signature
l'après midi mais si une journée temps
fort de l'événement avec aussi beaucoup
de larmes me suis dit oui oui c'est bien
parce que les parents peuvent assister
ils peuvent mettre au mur dans des
affiches ce qu'il entend ce qu'il
propose
oui c'est bien sûr le côté pratique
toutes ces animations elles se font sur
sur inscription faut s'inscrire pour
partir dans ses relations parfois non
non ça va et ça vient c'est entrée libre
est-ce que c'est gratuit c'est gratuit
d'accord et en quels objectifs du coup
pour pour cette semaine qu est ce qui
ferait que cette semaine de l'éducation
souhaite une réussite pour la ville mais
je pense que c'est le fait de faire
connaître le pays endetté le contenu de
tout ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur
on nous a souvent comme beaucoup
d'actions eux reprochés de pas
suffisamment communiqué hélas cette fois
on a voulu faire un temps fort au moins
pour le lancement voilà on a des
conférences intéressantes avec des gens
qui s'intéressent à la ville dont
monsieur qui a fait un rapport sur le
travail de l'élève en classe et hors
classe qui a déplacé une de ses
activités pour être absolument présence
est certainement lui qui dirigera le
prochain comité scientifique éducation
et tout le programme et a retrouvé il
est fourni ce programme sur le site de
la ville des trappes point fr merci à
jeanine mari d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes la première maire
adjointe de trappes en charge notamment
de l'éducation
allez une page sports tout de suite dans
ce journal
[Musique]
par ce moyen de nous rejoindre en
plateau avec michael demi d'euros
bonsoir mais qu'elle vous avez fait vite
alors vous nous parler chaque semaine
des des résultats sportifs du week end
sim traditionnelle chronique
alors il ya du football aujourd'hui au
coeur de cette chronique est direction
versailles on jouait ce week-end ce
dimanche le 7e tour de la coupe de
france
et oui grégory dé versailles et ce sont
à qualifier pour le 8e tour en
s'imposant à domicile contre les
tahitiens de l' as dragon les deux buts
de cette partie ont été inscrits en
première période on écoute le milieu du
fc versailles oussama berkak au micro de
notre journaliste mélanie poké on est
satisfait de votre passé de passer le
tour c'est une satisfaction c'était une
chose qu'on avait à coeur de faire et
l'essentiel a été fait les deux buts en
première mi temps après on aurait aimé
marquer plus de buts en seconde période
mais bon tant qu'il ya la qualif au bout
c'est ce qu'on voulait je vous propose
maintenant de regarder l'une des actions
du match grégory anjou la deuxième
période et c'est à ce moment là que
marama vahirua l'ancien joueur de ligue
1 passé par nantes lorient ou monaco
réalise ce geste
regardez les déraisons pied 38 ans voilà
coup franc sur le poteau
voilà il ya des restes un vous l'avez
dit précédemment ça ne sourit
malheureusement pas aux tahitiens les
versailles l'emportent mais les
polynésiens sorte avec la tête haute
on a beaucoup travaillé mais notre
premier adversaire aujourd'hui c'était
quand même le voir et le vent donc du
coup c'est compliqué pour nous surtout
quand on vient ici en pleine période
chaude chez nous avec un taux de
l'humidité qui passe qui dépasse les
100%
ce sont des hommes avant d'aider
footballeur avec des convictions avec
cette envie
élevé de défendre lors leur île leur
identité et leur club le club n'avait
plus atteint 1 8e tour de coupe de
france depuis à 7 ans le tirage au sort
du 8e tour sera effectué ce mardi 20
novembre à 19 heures exactement les
versailles et pourrait recevoir un club
de ligue 2 grégory la rencontre se
disputera quant à elle le 8 décembre
prochain
versailles qualifié du coup mickaël est
ce que c'est le dernier club des
yvelines
et oui malheureusement versailles est
bien le dernier club en course dans
cette coupe de france l' aventure
s'arrête donc au 7e tour pour carrière
gré sion le club qui évolue en première
division de district a été éliminé par
le charité sur loire
l'équipe de nationale 3 malgré les
quatre divisions d'écart le petit poucet
national s'est incliné 2 1 après avoir
ouvert le score à 20 minutes de la fin
du match par samir rivière une défaite
donc au goût amer à les yvelinois ne
rencontreront donc pas un club
professionnel dans cette coupe de france
merci michael cette information football
et bien d'autres encore à retrouver dans
votre émission le 7-8 sport juste après
ce journal ce sujet à elancourt ou une
compétition à de grs était organisée
dimanche au palais des sports avec plus
de 300 athlètes retour avec mélanie poké
vous amical et demi d'euros des cerceaux
des ballons et des figures
spectaculaires bienvenue sur cette
compétition interdépartemental de gr le
rendez vous était organisée cette année
par le club d'elancourt maurepas sur
deux jours les 17 et 18 novembre au
palais des sports d'elancourt tient
quatre départements
pas forcément tous les clubs donc c'est
vraiment mélanger il ya 4
lieu en ile-de-france qui fondent et
interdépartementale et il ya à peu près
3 125 gymnastes il ya tous les âges de
dix ans jusqu'à plus de 18 ans je sais
pas quel âge à la dernière et c'est par
catégorie alors il ya les catégories
d'âge et catégories de niveau parmi les
320 gymnastes présence certains se sont
entraînés pendant plusieurs mois pour
être prêt le jour j
beaucoup d'entraînement parce que les
façons il faut s'entraîner ça prend du
temps
j'ai bien détaillé tout le monde
enchaînement partie par partie
c'est beau non
trois cours par semaine et ça fait six
heures par semaine de cours du coup
c'est quand même beaucoup pour réaliser
des performances de haut niveau les 19
compétiteurs du club d'elancourt
maurepas ont voulu profiter de
l'avantagé d'évoluer à domicile a
l'habitude de s'entraîner sur les
praticables avoir la saline extra doux
c'est un peu plus simple
le club est en cours maurepas est
finalement ressorti de la compétition
avec sept podiums dont quatre premières
places la structure pourrait de nouveau
accueillir la compétition l'année
prochaine avant de vous quitter prudents
cette nuit sur les routes des yvelines
des chutes de neige sont attendues dans
le département placé en vigilance jaune
par météo france à partir de 1h du matin
le département en commun avec les
hauts-de-seine a activé son plan de
surveillance des voies et les cumuls de
neige pourraient atteindre 2 cm par
endroits la neige qui ne devrait
cependant pas tenir dans la journée de
demain mardi
c'est la fin du set 8 journal une
édition à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]